bei uns im studio ist peter tiger der
für uns aus moskau und aus russland
berichtet hat während des krieges und
peter du hast einen artikel dazu
geschrieben das war der auftakt gestern
für einen regelrechten horror tag für
wladimir putin das läuft dann wirklich
überhaupt nicht und dann kommt noch
sonntag also man sagt immer so erst pech
und dann kommt noch pech dazu wladimir
putin es läuft entweder im feld noch
politisch noch personell und er hat
tatsächlich ja sagen wir so um gestern
richtigen horror tag hab erstmal kam und
wieder verschärfte sanktionen mit dazu
er kann nicht mehr in gold handeln das
ist ein geschenk von durch die usa man
hat gemerkt dass ich mir putin die
währungs- und die finanzsanktionen
umgehen wollte durch den goldhandel
gestrichen dann hat die nato ihre
truppen erhöht dann hat japan neue
sanktionen gemacht die usa haben die
gesamte summe also jeden einzelnen
abgeordneten +80 andere leute aus dem
politischen umfeld noch mal mit
sanktionen belegt das rad hat sich
einmal durch kann man einmal durch
diesen schönen auf bild de es ist quasi
so eine strichliste wie putin gestern
der ganze tag verhandelt worden das fing
an mit einem untergehenden ich glaube
dieser rat auch noch ein zweites boot
ist wohl dann später auch noch gesunken
also es war wirklich ein ganz schwarzer
tag da hat der personalprobleme die
leute laufen weg sein wir haben schon
mal gesagt tschubais seien eigentlich
engster vertrauter auch aus sankt
petersburger zeiten der ihn nach moskau
geholt hat einst in den 90er jahren
abgehauen ist gestern wurde gesehen beim
geldabheben in der türkei wieder normal
rose einfach am geldautomaten früher
konnten alle rosen in der türkei jetzt
kann es nur noch weiß und die anderen
die alle fliehen das sind wirklich
bittere bilder für wladimir putin und
ich empfehle einfach mal den text auf
bild de zu lesen ist kann man nachlesen
da würde man sich auch nicht wohlfühlen
aber wir sind auch keine kriegsjahren
und wir dürfen da schadenfreude
empfinden wir empfinden das so du sagst
er fühlt sich nicht wohl tut er das dann
wirklich also sitzt und denkt so misst
es läuft alles nicht oder ist ja immer
noch selbstbewusst und sagte ja das kann
ich nicht unser kopf rein gucken aber
sagen wir mal jeder normale mensch gut
kommen auch schwer sagen mit reden von
wladimir putin aber das kann ihnen nicht
gefallen das geht gar nicht sein krieg
kommt nicht vom fleck seine truppen
stecken im matsch fest er hat noch nicht
einmal mario pohl überlegen das ist die
ost ukraine das ist 80 kilometer hinter
der grenze das sollte eigentlich
überfahren werden und dann auf dem weg
zur krim da stecken sie immer noch das
ist ein absolutes unglück ein unheil das
da angerichtet wird es ist ein schwert
eines der schwersten kriegsverbrechen
die wir glaube ich in den letzten 100
jahren gesehen haben oder letzten 80
jahren gesehen hat die stadt wird dem
erdboden gleichgemacht und die bewohner
gleich mal mit aber immer noch nicht
eingenommen er hat das minimalziel noch
immer nicht erreicht und seine truppen
stecken fest langsam werden auch
bestimmte waffen
nach mangelware dann muss er im fernen
osten jetzt schon reservisten einziehen
die denn die kaserne dann am laufen
halten weil im fernen osten kein soldat
mehr dass wir die berufssoldaten alle in
der ukraine sind 3000 hat er noch um
übungen auf den kurilen zu machen um
gegen japan ein bisschen rum zu drohen
das sind die inseln ganz im fernen osten
würde man sich jemand mit japan streitet
hat jetzt noch mal 3000 leute hin
geschickt um noch mal ein bisschen
hockey spielen zu lassen aber kein guter
tag wir bleiben gleichzeitig sehen wir
bilder von aktivisten auch wollen wir
allen spielen kannst du kommentieren
peter dann reden wir da auch ein das
sehen wir hier das
ist eine demonstration und dann sieht
man das sind bild das sind bis mitte
türen und zwar von drei verschiedenen
aktivistinnen in in moskau und hier noch
andere so wird sich an leuten gerecht
die gegen den king demonstrieren oder
die auch nur vagen fragen zu stellen das
ist eine junge maus und das sind junge
moskauerin sportlerin der scp schmiert
vom bz und mit verräter und so werden
die gebrandmarkt hat die schweine köpfe
werden für die türen gelegt ja wir haben
ein foto von der fronttür weiß ich aber
dass gerade vorliegen hat das sind hier
auch aktivistinnen den die türen so
beschmiert wurde sind und das ist die
die eingangstür zur wohnung vom
chefredakteur von echo moskwy dem
letzten freien radio dass er auch
eingestellt wurde ist ein schweinekopf
und an der tür ist ein aufkleber mit dem
ukrainischen staat symbol und der
aufschrift der deutschen aufschrift
juden sei das ist der alltag in moskau
für leute die nur vagen irgendwie
kritisch zu sein ein journalist dieses
radiosenders nämlich maxime könig auf
den hatten wir gestern hier bei uns in
der sendung wir noch einmal ganz kurz
mit ihr zusammen peter auch noch mal
rein was er uns erzählt hat
unser chefredakteur hat alle zusammen
und gesagt
dass diejenigen sehr gut verstehen kann
die ausweisen wollen und auch diejenigen
die bleiben wollen er sagte wir werden
trotzdem auch über youtube versuchen
weiter zu senden und
angehört und sehr viele waren das aber
danach
wir dann gezwungen den youtube-kanal
wenn sie den krieg als krieg bezeichnen
dann laufen sie gefahr dass ein
verfahren gegen sie eröffnet wird und da
können sie bis zu 15 oder gar 15 jahre
in den bau wandern
deshalb musst du ja auch bei deiner
berichterstattung immer militärische
sonderoperation sagen statt krieg hat
die anführungszeichen dazu gemacht also
ein radiosender einer der wenigen
unabhängigen die dort noch waren auch
dicht gemacht wie bekommen die russen
jetzt noch
informationen die tatsächlich der
wahrheit entsprechen also wenn man radio
und fernsehen an macht einfach gar nicht
mehr das ist vorbei man kann noch die
neue jetta lesen die aber zum beispiel
auch im archiv online alle artikel die
sie vor inkrafttreten dieses gesetzes
geschrieben haben zum krieg gelöscht
haben auch alle fotos man kann sich
informieren man muss wissen wo es gibt
immer noch telegramm und das ist ein
russischer erfindung und da sind die
informationen weitgehend frei verfügbar
wenn man will kann man sie haben die
problem ist dass die meisten russen das
glauben was ihnen im fernsehen erzählt
wird das ist leider gottes die masse es
gibt die ausnahmen es gibt die anderen
die sich informieren aber was mit ihnen
passiert wenn sie wenn sie dann auch nur
laut sagen was sie denken es gibt ja
also gedankenfreiheit ist nicht mehr
gegeben pressefreiheit ist nicht mehr
gegeben redefreiheit ist nicht mehr
gegeben demonstrationsfreiheit ist nicht
mehr gegeben die wandern dann in dem bau
oder werden behandelt
man muss es fast so bitter sagen wie wir
es aus deutschland oder unsere
großeltern oder urgroßeltern noch aus
ganz finsteren zeiten kennen das sie
gebrandmarkt werden was ist social media
instagram facebook ist das noch
verfügbare guten also man kann über ein
vpn tunnel gehen jetzt für die die sich
ein bisschen auskennen gibt die
möglichkeit dass man sich quasi ins
ausland durch tunnel und dann kommt man
daran dass ist das eine kleine software
muss man halt installieren dann kann man
die meisten sachen noch und wie nutzen
aber grundsätzlich alles verboten es
gibt eine ganz kuriose geschichte von
heute das die großen lebensmittel
hersteller an die staatsanwaltschaft an
die sonderstaatsanwaltschaft appelliert
haben das verbot der logos von facebook
ins da kann man von einem verbotenen
social-media-plattform aufzuheben
zumindest für lebensmittelverpackungen
daher ist ja überall facebook logo drauf
wenn sie eine facebook seite haben haben
die dann facebook logo drauf gedrückt
gedruckt mit ihrer adresse und das ist
verboten jetzt sie müssten das
eigentlich alles vernichten das heißt
sie müssen die ganzen die ganzen
verpackung kartonagen alles wegschmeißen
das geld haben sie nicht das material
haben sie nicht sie müssten die regale
einmal herum es ist komplett irre wasser
gerade abläuft dann ist er ja
merkwürdigen ereignisse die du erlebt
hast also in moskau war war als
plötzlich gerhard schröder in geheimer
mission dort aufgetaucht ist wir kennen
alle das ikonische zu sagen ich mal
seiner frau betend sozusagen vor dem
kreml wir haben lange darauf gewartet
dass er sich mal öffentlich äußert
gestern war es dann tatsächlich so weit
aber nicht vor der haustür in hannover
um sich eindeutig von putin zu
distanzieren sondern er ist ein
geschäftsmann bei einem business meeting
in der türkei und wir haben wir rein was
er gesagt hat
today we
consider important landmark
discussion with
first
nein die november nine team hinein
sowohl the
berlin wall
mittwochs related to the opening
aufteilen könnten in europe and
ob sie bei polaris
united states and assume that time that
we have not created security structure
and reflect the change situation
ist wollen ob sie konsequenzen
ob sie's politiker
also man haben sie haben wir haben extra
mal in englisch stehen lassen und ich
habe nicht darüber gesprochen zum einen
damit man die stimme von gerhard
schröder mal wieder höher kann und zum
anderen um also irgendwie sein englisch
denn so ist was er gesagt hat war im
wesentlichen dass sie die
sicherheitsstruktur in europa nach 1989
nach dem fall der mauer einfach nicht
konsequent neu geordnet worden sei und
was ja auch noch gesagt hatte in einem
anderen an einer anderen stelle war das
natürlich krieg keine lösung sei aber
dass die sicherheitsinteressen aller
seiten berücksichtigt werden müssen und
alle in klammern auf bedeutet dann auch
die der russischen seite ihr mann gerd
schröder glaubt dann ist diese ukraine
kriegt einfach als reife frucht von
einem baum gefallen aber das ist für ein
ungeheurer glitzernde sei eine ziemliche
frechheit also er sagt im prinzip weil
wir der westen und russland vielleicht
auch noch vergessen haben in den 90er
jahren frühen 2001 eine neue
sicherheitsarchitektur zu installieren
ist dieser ukraine krieg entstanden das
ist eine konsequenz daraus dass sagte
also für ihn ist der krieg logisch
herleitbar er leitet diesen krieg
logisch her als reife frucht vom baum
gefallen ich weiß nicht was man dafür
machen muss um auch den gedanken zu
kommen und die noch auszusprechen
wahrscheinlich rechts aus auf der
falschen seite zuständen das heißt ja
eine sicherheitsarchitektur geschaffen
worden es gab die vier plus zwei
gespräche bislang kein geld worden
russland war dabei ist sodann hat alle
verträge unterschrieben wladimir putin
alle verträge anerkannt und auch für die
altschulden das ist alles ein papier so
gerd schröder bekommt ja recht viel
gegenwind auch hier aus deutschland und
seiner eigenen partei muss man ja auch
sagen man fragt sich wirklich warum
äußert er sich jetzt und
dann muss ich daraus kann ganz genau
sagen dafür gibt's geld ist unbezahlter
redner der da hat auch ein gutes
verhältnis zu herrn erdogan das hat
vielen leuten auch genutzt das hat er
auch zum guten mal genutzen beispiel hat
er die welt ist ein tennis-duell mit
befreit da war mit dafür verantwortlich
dass seine kontakte für genutzt aber
hätte er doch einfach nur mal wieder
geschwiegen wir wollen uns noch was
anderes anschauen was
ungewöhnlich ist in den letzten tagen
sind die bilder
aufgekommen und zwar
werden verstorbene also gefallene
soldaten russische soldaten jetzt von
der ukraine mit gesichtserkennung
erfasst und diese bilder werden dann
abgeglichen mit profilen in sozialen
medien um dann die mütter insbesondere
zu informieren die angehörigen zu
informieren dass ihre söhne dort
gefallen sind das ist nicht reine
nächstenliebe sondern das hatte auch
hintergründe darüber sprechen wir gleich
noch mal aber wir schauen uns das man
am 24 februar marschieren putin soldaten
in die ukraine ein tausende menschen
sind durch den russischen angriffskrieg
bereits gestorben darunter auch viele
der eigenen russischen soldaten um ihren
familien gewissheit zu verschaffen setzt
die ukraine neuerdings die
gesichtserkennungssoftware claire juli 1
der hersteller den ukrainischen behörden
ein kostenlosen zugang bereit gestellt
der stellvertretende ministerpräsident
der ukraine und minister für digitale
transformation michael o federer auf
sagte dazu
aus höflichkeit gegenüber den müttern
dieser soldaten verbreiten wir diese
information über die sozialen medien
damit die familien zumindest wissen dass
sie ihre söhne verloren haben und damit
sie die möglichkeit haben die toten
abzuholen von den 10 milliarden fotos in
dessen datenbank sollen zwei milliarden
ausbau kontakte stammen einem sozialen
netzwerk das oft als russisches pendant
zu facebook beschrieben wird wie fedorov
bestätigt wird die gesichtserkennung
genutzt um die social media zugänge
toter russischer soldaten zu finden
zudem können die technologie verwendet
werden um getrennte familien wieder
zusammenzuführen oder russische agenten
zu identifizieren nun es ist tatsächlich
sehr schwer mit dieser atemberaubende
veränderung der technologie im letzten
monat vorzustellen so etwas wäre noch
vor kurzem undenkbar gewesen
kritiker werfen der ukraine allerdings
vor die software für ihre form der
propaganda zu missbrauchen
denn es soll russische familien warnen
dass ihre lieben in folge eines
sinnlosen krieges gestorben sind diese
software sei daher ein unmoralisches
instrument die stimmung in der
russischen bevölkerung zu brechen
also aus höflichkeit wurde da gesagt
aber peter natürlich ist es nicht nur
höflichkeit denn die russischen mutter
spielen eine ganz besondere rolle in
russland auch in diesem krieg sind sie
soldatenmütter weil es erstens der
schweiz russland immer das ausmaß der
eigenen verluste dann wird den leuten
nicht erzielt und wo und wie ihre
angehörigen gestorben sind die männer
und die söhne was ist in der regel so
dass die netze sind bei einer übung ums
leben kommen oder aber sonst wohnen wird
auch nicht erzählt wo er die leichen
sind oftmals also ich selber war in der
region tage an rock das ist unten und
kurze von mario pohl aber auf der
russischen seite mal auf einem friedhof
da sind soldaten einfach heimlich
verscharrte von 2014 und zwar auf dem
lieben friedhof der ist für amputierte
beine oder für tote föten da werden die
einfach verscharrt namenlos und die
russen die russen das immer verschweigen
oftmals die meldung auch wirklich mit
wochen oder monaten verspätung bei den
familien ankommen einfach um zu
verhindern dass während des krieges eine
bestimmte stimmung auf komponierten die
mütter dieser organisiert sind übrigens
auch gebrandmarkt als ausländische
agenten jetzt dass diese organisation
das irgendwie öffentlich macht und von
daher man kann das kritisieren ich finds
richtig weil sonst erfahren die nicht
für ihre kinder sind wohl wo ihre söhne
sind wir fahren nicht wann und wo die
gestorben sind und wir erinnern uns
einfach mal an den zweiten weltkrieg und
bis heute werden die leichen von
deutschen soldaten in russland in der
ukraine und in weißrussland ausgegraben
und werden gesucht und auch in polen und
bis heute wissen viele familien nicht wo
die geblieben sind die russischen
familien erfahren es wenigstens aber
meinst du das klappt wirklich dieses
system also da wird über facebook dann
gesucht dann wird vielleicht auch über
facebook ein familienangehöriger an
geschmack hat ja auch eben gesagt heißt
abgeschaltet du musst die bilder haben
und die meisten bilder stammen von
stammt von frau kontakte vollkontakt die
ist so eine art russisches ponton zu zu
zu facebook übrigens von dem mann
gemacht worden und gebaut worden der
dann auch telekom später gemacht hatte
russland die auch verlassen musste und
da sind die bilder vorhanden wenn man
die einmal im stock hat also wenn du die
anderen lager hast dann kannst du die
auch verwendet dann weiß doch zu welchem
profilen die er gehört haben wie gesagt
man kann das kritisieren ich finde das
richtig weil es konnte hat auch die
desinformationen der russen im eigenen
land gegenüber den eigenen leuten aus
und wie mit ihren opfern umgehen weiß
machen und die wirkung ist groß auch
sinn lenski wendet sich ja immer wieder
an die russischen soldaten mütter und
wie soldatenmütter sind natürlich wir
haben natürlich auch kontakt zu zu denen
aber die können ja kaum noch irgendetwas
sagen die dürfen nicht über den krieg
reden tief die feinde unter die 15 jahre
die feinen unter dieses gesetz wenn sie
denn wenn die mutter in die organisation
der soldatenmütter ist mit ihren
informationen raus gehen und die
öffentlich sagen dann fallen sie unter
das verbotsgesetz und können zu 15 jahre
dafür ins gefängnis kommen dafür dass
sie einfach sagen wie viel sind
gesinnter gestorben dafür dass die
beispiele bringen das können sie nicht
nicht mehr aber natürlich um mord und
bei den müttern um mottos werden der
eigenen mutter und weiß wie eine mutter
für ein kind kämpft der weiß welche
wirkung die haben könnte amerikanischen
informationen 40.000 russische soldaten
entweder getötet verletzt oder gefangen
sind in weißrussland sind sind die
krankenhäuser voll auf und es gibt
berichte davon dass die leute die auf
normalstation liegen nicht schlafen
können weil von den anderen stationen
die schreie kommen weil er die
verletzten russischen soldaten liegen es
fahren leichten dran transporte von
weißrussland rüber nach russland fliegen
flugzeuge ganz vieles ein teil da andere
sind in den sind in den grenzregionen in
den gesamten krankenhäusern in taganrog
zum beispiel rostov am don und wenn man
dann hoch geht einmal um die ganze rum
dann in allen großen krankenhäusern ein
militär aus mit tellern liegen die
verwundeten und sowjetischen russischen
soldaten und ganz oft wissen die
familienangehörigen nicht was mit ihm
passiert ist und viele von denen kommt
tatsächlich auch aus sozialen
verhältnissen und noch aus dem fernen
osten also hinten aus sibirien wirklich
im fernen sibirien
und da sind die leute komplett in
absoluter ahnungslosigkeit und das
gehört mit dazu so führt russland krieg
und wenn die ukraine dem entgegensteuert
ich find es nicht verwerflich ich finde
es richtig